c'est un meuble préféré parce que il est
très simple très sobre et on reste
toujours dans l'inspiration années 50 et
il suffit vraiment d'une petite touche
colorée pour apporter vraiment toute la
simplicité
toutes les composantes de cette table
design années 50 ont été récupérés dans
les encombrants ou en déchetterie avec
ce métier de designer reaper le
recyclage prend ses lettres de noblesse
dans cette usine désaffectée de saint
paterne racan des menuisiers en
insertion vont produire 200 meubles pour
des logements étudiants de la ville de
tours
c'est un projet qui à la fois un projet
qui permet d'économiser de la ressource
de la matière parce que tous les meubles
sont la plupart sont des meubles en bois
avec un savoir faire donc ça veut dire
qu'on pérennise savoir faire et qu'on
évite de couper des forêts du bois pour
refaire des meubles
la nouveauté dans cette fabrique
écologique et solidaire c'est
l'intervention du design associé à du
recyclage un procès ce qui valorise ce
mobilier de récupération mais aussi ceux
qui les fabriquent
produire ces objets mobiliers à partir
de déchets est extrêmement valorisant
pour les nouvelles équipes les nouvelles
formes d' équipe que l'on met en place
pour fabriquer donc des gens d'insertion
qui viennent se former mais pas mais se
former vraiment un métier des jeunes
designers qui deviennent des designers
rip serre qu'ils vont chercher la
ressource dans les encombrants ou dans
les recycleries
recyclage circuits courts insertion le
tout à la mode des années 50
d'une époque au coeur du projet de
réhabilitation de la future résidence
étudiante à meubler c'est important
qu'on puisse être vertueux c'est que le
projet de réhabilitation les on a fait
le choix de réhabiliter cet immeuble en
respectant le caractère années 50 l'idée
c'était également de le meubler avec ce
même caractère années 50 donc le
mobilier sera réhabilité sera installée
en respectant cet objectif
avec style les discours sur l'écologie
le social deviennent ici concret
l'économie circulaire vient une réalité